well seven veterans were laid to rest  today at the va cemetery in boulder city  while they were not claimed by family  members they were not alone in their  final resting place this morning as  local groups women veterans of nevada  has been accompanying vets like them for  nearly 20 years in weekly ceremonies  this is the first time we've had this  many people come out and this is  wonderful i mean i get goosebumps just  thinking about it that  people are coming out to honor our  fallen veterans who have no family  because we are their family the vice  president of the organization says  sometimes it takes a while for vets to  be identified but it's worth it to give  them an honorable and dignified burial